based on a popular video game Five
Nights at Freddy's has expanded out to a
full-on franchise with other media lots
of merch and now it's first live action
adaptation but you don't need to totally
geek out on all of it that is why we're
here this is everything you need to know
before you go see Five Nights at
Freddy's tell me how to stop
them so we've got five quick to topics
for Five Nights at Freddy's pun intended
a brief history of the video game a look
at the animatronic characters and also
the human characters plus what the movie
is about and a look at its journey and
who made it all happen oh it all began
with the first video game of the same
title created by Scott coffin and
released in August of 2014 I always
thought it's a little Eerie that his
last name rhymes with coffin but I mean
listen he found his Niche the game play
for it includes users taking on the role
of nighttime security guard Mike Schmidt
as he defend ends himself against cursed
animatronics which you got to admit is
just pretty genius because there's no
way that you walked into Chuck-E-Cheeses
and weren't spooked by that feathery
bird one or the dog with the banjo the
game also includes things like a camera
system doors with lights and the
previous Night Guard known as phone guy
and now just nine short years later
there is a total of nine main Series
games along with six spin-off games and
that doesn't even include the fan
versions that c and himself has helped
fund and publish and as I mentioned
along with this movie the games have
also spawned a novel Trilogy a series of
short stories and some graphic novels
and don't forget about the plethora of
merchandise I mean you're totally going
to want a t-shirt after you learn about
the animatronics also this is a killer
Halloween costume idea if you want to
dress up with your friends now speaking
of the Tronics Five Nights at Freddy's
which centers around a now shuttered
pizza place called Freddy Fazbear's
Pizza features four main animatronic
characters aka the band now of course
there is the front man Freddy Fazbear
himself generally wearing a top hat hat
and a tie looking oh so Chic then you
got backup singer chica who's a chicken
wearing a yellow Bib and she has a side
snack named Mr Cupcake which don't we
all am I right I'm talking about food
here and then there's the guitar playing
bunny named Bonnie and the red pirate
fox named naturally foxy who has an eye
patch and a hook hand I mean who
wouldn't want to host their kids'
birthday there in s uncomfortable laugh
here now in the games the animatronics
start to take on more freaky iterations
which also seems likely here especially
because the trailer shows these
animatronics to be kidp possessed of
course the games have introduced more
scary animatronics and other Freddy
Fazbear locations which could be good
material for some sequels which have
actually been teased at but now it's
time for us to talk about the boring old
humans although it is good to see our
friend Josh Hutcherson again so he's the
one playing the previously mentioned
nighttime security guard Mike Schmidt
not to be confused with the ' 80s
baseball player for the Phillies by the
way not that you would but there's
probably someone out there that's
thinking about it anyways you may
remember Josh from The Hunger Games
movies as jayla's L bro SL lover
question mark and from what we can tell
from the Five Nights at Freddy's
trailers he's pretty good at screaming
so he's going to be
great joining Mike Schmidt is his little
sister Abby played by the young Piper
Rubio now this is a bit of a left turn
from the games which doesn't feature a
young protagonist until the fourth
installment so this could be a nod to
that or after the success of The Last of
Us people basically learned in love that
it always raises a Stakes to have a hit
along for the ride also appearing in
human form is Matthew Lillard bringing
that horror movie veteran presence to
the film given his performance in the
first Scream Scream by the way is my
Roman Empire for those of you wondering
I'll be right back so Lillard is listed
as playing someone named Steve Raglin
which is most likely a false identity
but I'm personally excited to see what
happens with his character cuz you know
Scooby-Doo man he's so good just another
beautiful day in paradise Elizabeth L
from the Netflix show you is playing
Vanessa who we also meet in the trailers
and we know that Mary Stewart Masterson
Fried Green Tomatoes anyone is playing
some sort of villain named Aunt Jane hey
Auntie as far as where The Story Goes we
know that the original story of Mike
Schmidt getting hired as an overnight
security guard at a closed down pizza
place will be at the core of course
he'll discover what's really going on
AKA a bunch of crazy animatronics that
will literally kill anyone who's still
in the building after midnight and what
is it about that time that's just so
transformative I mean for Mike and
Cinderella anyway but from there we
don't know much more about the story but
since franchise Creator Scott cin served
as the executive producer and co-writer
there are bound to be some Easter eggs
for you hardcore fans let's talk about
the journey now now the talks of a film
began actually back in 2015 not long
after the first game dropped various
directors were attached along the way
including Home Alone Chris Columbus but
the project eventually made it over to
the blumhouse production company and
Emma Tommy signed on to direct she also
co-wrote it in a seen some horror
experience having directed 2018s The
Wind now of course that move meant that
Jason Blom was a producer on this one a
guy who has his hand in so many great
horror projects and by the way if you
didn't know this Five Nights at Freddy's
is actually rated PG-13 which can make
horror a bit more challenging but it's
definitely doable especially with this
kind of brain power behind the scenes so
my friends that is everything you need
to know before you go see Five Nights at
Freddy's and theaters and it's streaming
on peacock on October 27th just in time
for Halloween my name is Nas Perez and
thanks for watching this video be sure
to check out our other no Before You Go
episodes so you're all ready to go
before you head to the theater and as
always be sure to rate and review this
film at Rotten tomatoes.com we love
knowing how you feel and
[Music]
[Applause]
think